hello
humans and other assorted life forms
it's january 25th
2021 there is a lot going on in the
world we're doing four stories
today and they're sort of all over the
place because i want to give you a
holistic
view of the world without making you
completely insane
uh before i do anything else today
though uh you probably heard the news
that
my friend my mentor my
sort of uncle or bonus grandfather
and and just guy i admired and loved so
much
larry king passed away over the weekend
larry was 87
he had had a series of health issues
over the years
a bunch of heart attacks and bypass
surgeries and cancer and all sort of
stuff he had
a very difficult year this year two of
his adult children
passed away over the last couple months
his brother had died
not long before that it had been a rough
rough time for larry on top of
coveted and everything else i just want
to say
to larry wherever you are and how much i
love and admire
you and thank you for making me think
that i could do something even halfway
decent
as an interviewer or whatever it is that
i am at this point
um every moment that i spent with larry
was like
truly magical whether it was on camera
although usually the magical ones were
were off camera when i got to know them
in different way and i shared this story
on the reuben report locals community a
couple days ago or two days ago i
suppose
um but i thought i would just share one
one thing with you because i think it's
it's uh well it's worth mentioning
in light of everything going on in the
world right now and sort of how crazy
everybody feels
um i saw larry a few times right before
a lockdown and
and he had had some health stuff and had
been in and out of hospitals already
and one time i saw him and he was really
kind of banged up
and and not feeling great and i kind of
when i left his house i
sort of thought it was like oh that's
probably the last time that i was going
to see him and then i called him about a
week later
and i said larry how you doing and he
goes he goes david you always call me
david who goes
david i'm laying on the table the doctor
the doctor's poking me right now i said
well how you feeling
he goes doc how am i feeling i just
thought it was like it was just so
funny and perfect like it was just the
way he was like as he had doctors like
poking a doc how am i feeling
tell dave how i'm feeling doc i'm doing
a little more rodney dangerfield i think
than uh
than larry king um but then about a week
later when he got home again i did get
to see him
and he was there with uh with two of his
sons one of whom is
one of the ones that passed away and
then one of his younger sons um
and uh he was in a wheelchair at the
time and we were chatting and
having lunch and he said i want to show
you the trophy room
and i wheeled him into the trophy room
and we stood there and the trophy room
in his house was he had a room in his
house
that was basically all the awards all
the accolades all the notes
and plaques and all of the things the
gifts that he had been given by all of
the incredible people he had
interviewed over the years from all of
the presidents and the secretaries of
state and the pope
and just everybody that he had
interviewed the pictures the sign
things all of it and we were standing
there and most of it
so one side was all of like the the
political stuff and the interview stuff
and the other side was a lot of baseball
memorabilia and we were staring
at the at the political side you know
the show side you know the emmys all of
that stuff
and i kind of wheeled him in front of it
we were just standing there and
uh he goes he goes what's it all about
dave what's it all about
and you know when you have those moments
where it's like you don't even have time
to
to think of anything and just sort of
whatever was going to come out of my
mouth came out of my mouth and i just
looked at him and i said larry this
this is what it's all about like this
this is a life worth living
and we just kind of sat there we sat
there we didn't really say much for like
three or four minutes
um and then and then his son came in and
we got out of there
and uh i don't know it was just like an
incredible moment like he knew
like his time was limited and
you know just looking at all of the
stuff that he had done and not that that
was
the sum totality of his life right he
had many children
just the amount of people that adored
him and how much he loved baseball and
all sorts of other stuff
um but it was just a i don't know it's
just a very special moment for me
and for any of you that watch and
appreciate what i do if i'm
you know five percent of the interviewer
that that guy was i will take that so
larry
i will always be thinking of you and i
miss you already and
i hope you're on to greener pastures all
right my friends uh
let's move on so there is some actually
believe it or not there's
some potentially good news coming out of
california today i i actually can't
believe it but it is possible
supposedly in approximately an hour from
now
this is the rumor on the computer there
uh the rumor is that gavin newsom our
horrific
awful terrible to be recalled governor
uh is going to end at least part of
the statewide lockdown it is unclear
exactly what that will mean
i'm hearing a rumor that that may not
include la that it'll include every
other part of california but maybe not
la in which case
i'm going to actually you're going to
tomorrow i won't be doing a show because
my brain will have exploded in my head
and pieces will ever
be everywhere and they're gonna have to
piece me together um but let's just
assume that it's gonna be everything and
that some restaurants will open outdoor
eating
and hopefully some of these mom and pop
shops can get up to it
uh back to work um but if you want a
little context
for this whole thing i think it's become
very obvious
that this all was about politics this
all was about destroying trump and
crushing
the economies enough so people would be
frustrated enough and they could blame
everything on trump even though trump
handed the power
to the governors you know this this
authoritarian hitler guy who was letting
the governors do what they thought was
best
um i i don't think newsom or cuomo or
any of these guys that have locked down
their states and destroyed
countless amounts of lives have any bit
of guilt or remorse or anything they've
done truly truly terrible things
um and it's just like think about it
this way if you were a small business
owner you just had a dream to open up
some shop
or a restaurant as i always say
something like 90 of restaurants fail in
the first year in normal times
how could you ever go ahead and do it in
one of these states ever again knowing
what the normal risks are
now on top of the fact that the
governments can just come in and shut
you down
at whims i mean i just it's just
absolutely incredible
but if you need some evidence that this
was really about politics
and not really about covid or keeping us
safe which i don't even think it's the
government's job to keep us safe
but if you need some evidence we should
look at these two charts that were put
up this is from the new york times
so on december 7th 2020 that's the day
they
shut down outdoor dining and you may
remember that
the woman who shut down outdoor dining
uh
miss cool her name is from what was her
first name sandra was it sandra cool
sheila cool sheila cool i actually
protested at her house a few days later
she uh voted she was the deciding vote
to shut down outdoor dining
then right from the vote she actually
went to go eat outside until they shut
down outdoor dining the next day so that
just shows you this
the hypocrisy and ridiculousness of
these people but the day we did the
outdoor shutdown we had 27
227 new cases of cobit our seven day
average
was 23 000 roughly now flash forward
five weeks later
new cases are 21 680 so a little bit
less
new cases but our seven day average
right now is actually higher
than it was five weeks ago it's at
twenty five thousand five hundred
seventy six
so if our new case average is
higher then how in the world does it
make sense to open the state if opening
if keeping us locked down had anything
to do with keeping us safe
i think it's fairly obvious that we all
know the answer to this that the
lockdowns
not only didn't work they actually were
completely
counter to everything because they
destroyed the economy and made people
depressed and we know
rates of alcohol and suicide are up and
the rest of it um
this is because uh that joe biden guy
was sworn in as president of the united
states six days ago this is the only
reason new york
opened up a little bit more since then
look i want all the states to open so i
will gladly take it
i will gladly take it but my hope
my hope is that over the next couple
months
and and year or so that as the
information trickles out as to how
they made these decisions how these
ridiculous authoritarian power hungry
lunatics
made these decisions my hope is that
there will be massive lawsuits
that there will be class action lawsuits
there will be lawsuits by restaurateurs
there will be lawsuits by regular
citizens whose lives were destroyed
and people like avenue some probably
should end up in jail
probably like i don't really see a way
around it like the damage that he has
done to society is far more
than the damage that our former attorney
general kamala harris
has put people into jail for here in
california
so uh i just want to say a special a
special message
it's been a while i haven't given a
special message in a while but i do have
a special message
for gavin newsom gavin newsom
you're getting recalled so you didn't
know what i was going to do there you
thought i might drop the f-bomb again
but i mixed it up on you
he's getting recalled let's recall this
guy it only needs i think it has
something like 1.3
out of the 1.5 million signatures to get
this guy recalled if you haven't signed
it and you're in california sign this
thing they don't make it easy because
you have to do it in person
while at the same time they're keeping
you locked down you think maybe he
wanted to keep people locked down so
they couldn't sign
his thing because you can't do it online
find your local place group
whatever and sign that recall gavin
uh situation because he he deserves to
go he really does deserve to go um and
look if if california opens tomorrow
if if la is open tomorrow i think that
i'm going to go outside
and have a chicken sandwich i'm going to
go to a restaurant
and have a fried chicken sandwich you
guys want to come with me what do you
want what do you want michael
what do you want spicy chicken sandwich
connor what do you want
two spicy chicken sandwiches so the
group of people
breaking the law by being in this room
right now i'm gonna have a regular
chicken sandwich
two spicy chicken sandwiches okay that's
what's gonna happen
god bless america um all right let's
switch over because i thought this was a
an interesting way to follow up that
story uh there are some studies out
right now
that have been released that trust in
the media has hit an all-time low
color me shocked can you believe it
people i just can't believe it are
wonderful media
like the new york times at cnn people
don't trust them
this is very very disturbing let's look
at some of the numbers
56 percent of people
polled believe that journalists and
reporters are purposely trying to
mislead
that so that means more than half of the
people think that journalists are
intentionally trying to lie to you
that's pretty interesting this is by
edelman polling 58 think that news
organizations are more interested in
ideology than facts
yes only 18 percent of republicans trust
the media
versus 57 percent of democrats i mean 18
a republican seems pretty high for the
republicans considering how awful the
media is
but that roughly 60 percent of democrats
even buy into this nonsense
just tells you how far the ship has
sailed uh as a whole 46
of americans of all political stripes
say they trust
the media and here's a fancy little
graph i like this little dump off here
uh as far as the percentage of americans
who trust
traditional media i mean look guys this
this should not surprise exactly what
the media has been they've been
gaslighting us
relentlessly they condone and excuse
violence when it's violence on the left
and they exaggerate it when it's
violence on the right
i have no problem telling you that i
condemn all political violence either
way whether it's antifa in portland
or whether it's right-wing political
violence in dc
but they simply cannot do that they
bring on democrats on all the shows to
help promote them and they bring on
republicans
usually to lie about them or cut them
off there was a really interesting video
yesterday
on uh abc what is it the george
stephanopoulos show in the morning
george stephanopoulos who is the head
this guy is in charge basically of abc's
political
news division he also worked in the bill
clinton white house you think he's a
democrat or a republican i mean i'm not
a
scientist but i think i can figure it
out he had rand paul on senator from
kentucky obviously libertarian i like
rand a lot and
rand brought up some points about how we
should continue to look into election
fraud that we want to secure our
elections
in the future and he started talking
about some of the things that happened
over the last couple months which we're
really not allowed to talk about here on
youtube
and george stephanopoulos said there are
not two sides to this story
i mean imagine being a journalist and
saying like just like no
blanket there are not two sides to this
story that's it these are again are the
same people
i would love if somebody could figure
out how many hours worth of content
has george stephanopoulos and abc put
out from 2016 to 2020
related to the russia hoax and related
to the covington kids and the brett
kavanaugh
stuff and uh jesse smellet and all of
the things that we all know turned out
to be lies but that fit their narrative
but in this issue about about either
election fraud or broadly anything that
conservatives
or libertarians believe there's sorry
one side to this story
just this it's so weird but this one
thing that we really really need you to
believe
that's the one thing that you know you
can't even look at another way you'd
have you'd be alex freaking jones you'd
be a complete
conspiracy nut bag you get it people do
you get it
which also actually believe it or not we
really did a hell of a job with the
segways today it segues perfectly into
the third story so i know you guys get
it people don't trust the media
okay well then there's another sort of
layer of what's going to happen i think
more and more
in the next couple years as we see the
biden harris administration or i should
say the harris biden administration
as they sort of navigate through the
media landscape and the big tech
landscape
and this story is probably going to seem
like a little bit of insider baseball to
you guys but i think it's i think it's
actually
pretty important so the biden white
house
team has shut off all comments
on their youtube videos now that's
pretty interesting
because it's like first off if it's a
governmental
website my general um
state my general position on this would
be that you'd want as much transparency
as possible and you just let the people
talk
right like you just have the comments
there and you'd let the people talk now
they know that
they would get ratioed to high hell they
know that most people wouldn't tune in
and we could just actually just look
back at the last few months
where every time trump did an event
there were hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people watching and then
biden would do an event in front of
three cars
and there would be basically nobody
watching and it would have all down
votes so what they're really trying to
say here is they don't want the people
commenting on things now a few of you
wise witty people
maybe noting that we here at the reuben
report don't have
comments on our live streams and that is
true now first off i want to be very
clear i'm not part of the us government
in case you didn't figure that out i
have no connection
with the government the reason that we
do it is because the way that these
ridiculous big tech algorithms are set
up
is that these the live streams become
the worst
sort of evil trolling bot lunacy
white supremacists crazy anti-semites
like just just the awful dredge of
society show up in the live stream
comments
believe it or not when we put the video
up immediately after we allow for
comments and our comments
on our videos actually have been really
great lately i do quickly try to glance
a little bit and i have my guys just
sort of take a temperature of what's
going on and they've been really good i
think that's probably
uh indicative of the type of content
we're putting out here but
anyway i mentioned that because
obviously we're not part of the
government
but they are but the really the bigger
issue here is okay so
let's say you've got all of the media
elite so you know that when biden
does interviews they're going to be
softball interviews you know the jen
pasaki the new white house
press secretary you know that she's
going to get softball questions we
played a couple of them last week
we know the media is going to focus all
the bad on trump like no matter what
happens
if biden starts a war in syria somehow
it will be related to something trump
did we
alright i think everybody gets the game
right like all of the kobit stuff it was
all horrible somehow this week we can
open up but trump was the guy with his
bad beforehand
okay fine fine the problem is that if
you have the layer of
just basically getting blow jobs from
the media right
and then that's that's a horrible visual
actually um but if you
if you have that and then you have okay
we're also going to post videos
on these mass communication sites like
youtube and people won't be able to
comment
and then on top of it we know that our
algorithms
are going to shadow ban people on
twitter so that they can't communicate
or
the way we'll manipulate algorithms on
youtube so people only see certain
things and what
whatever else is going on even the stuff
that we don't know about and i have no i
i have no doubt that there's plenty of
stuff we don't know about that in
essence
as i've been talking about for a long
time we are in an information war you'll
have a
sort of a state-run media and then
you'll have
videos that you can see online that you
can't comment on and then when you go to
the big tech
platforms they'll manipulate you in a
certain way and then you'll be reduced
to to figuring out other ways to
communicate with people one way you
might want to communicate with people
is at reubenreport.locals.com we are the
community is absolutely exploding
and you can say whatever you want you
can talk to other interesting people and
there's no
bots and trolls uh so so there you go
anyway so again as i said it feels like
a little bit of insider baseball to be
talking about youtube comments
um but in another way it's not because
it's just more
about like why are they really doing it
why are they like what was that they had
a meeting and they said
okay we're gonna put up videos on the
white house youtube channel that's what
presidents have done for the last you
know
10 years or so and then somebody said
well
we know that if we do that that there's
going to be a lot of people making fun
of us there's going to be a lot of
people calling us out
on our bs there's going to be a lot of
people whatever even if it was related
to trolls and bots like
there's gonna be a lot of and then they
said okay well let's just not
you know allow for a forum where the
citizens where the people of the united
states can
comment to us so that's what the real
risk is and i think we're gonna see more
and more of that and as
as government and tech just becomes one
thing that's going to be a big problem
and by the way
that's also why you know as
over the last couple years as there were
all these debates about what do you do
about big tech
i kept saying that the conservatives
have to watch out what they're asking
for that if you have trump do an
executive action
on big tech and regulate well
congratulations you've just tied
big tech back together with the
government
and i understand why a lot of
conservatives would have been for that
because trump would still be on these
platforms at the moment
but i think you maybe down the line
would have created a much bigger monster
and by the way guys
as i always say i'm a world weary
optimist and i have a belief that these
systems will fail
they will keep hiring the wrong people
the wrong engineers the wrong public
people
based not on their uh skills but on
these other immutable characteristics
and i think these things
will ultimately uh fail let me do one
other story
today okay and then there's a lot going
on here i got a busy day there's there's
just like so much happening with locals
right now i'm just in meeting after
meeting
uh but i want to do one other story
about uh
masks because you know i'm a believer as
i've said from from day one that you
should do what's right for you and if
you own a store and you want people to
wear masks that's fine and the
government
can give us recommendations on how we
want to behave but that
that basically is it but the new york
times
uh has now re recommended that we double
mask
so let's just back up for a second you
may remember
march do you remember march of 2020 it
seems like a lifetime ago
we were told two weeks to flatten the
curve there was nothing about locking
down the entire economy there was
nothing about
destroying millions of lives and the
rest of it but now we've gone from two
weeks to flatten the curve
to endless lockdowns to maybe kind of
opening up to restaurants that can be a
25
capacity that sounds like a profitable
motive oh on top of everything else
biden's pushing for this 15 minimum wage
and it's like if you ever wanted to
crush the remaining small businesses
what would you do
you would take them you would lock them
down you would say okay you can open up
a part capacity and you have to pay your
employees more like if you ever want to
destroy small businesses that's how you
do it you know who can afford
to pay for 15 minimum wage target
walmart etc etc now philosophically i
don't think the government should have
anything to do with minimum wage anyway
i believe in the market i think that's
the only roughly
fair way of doing anything although bad
things can happen just in the market
itself but i think those things have a
way of working themselves out
but the point is if you want to destroy
the last remaining small businesses as i
believe bernie sanders wants to do
as i believe joe biden now wants to do
what would you do you would you would
handicap them with all of these
lockdowns
and then you would say okay little mom
and pop sneakers store now you have to
pay
your stock boy 15 bucks guess what
target's not going to have a problem
doing that the big the big outlets and
the online retailers aren't going to
have a problem doing that and you will
crush
what's remaining but anyway
now they are telling us two masks we
went from two weeks to flatten the curve
to two masks
this is from the new york times two
masks are the new masks
double masking is a sensible and easy
way to lower your risk when you have to
spend more time around others
in a taxi on a train or plane or at an
inauguration um look again
do what's right for you do what's right
for your family
think it through and try to be a
responsible human being
also understanding that there is some
risk in life
but the idea that we're gonna wear two
masks why not three masks you know
how about a mask and a mask and a face
shield
and just like a giant body condom like a
naked gun like should we start doing
that would that be best
and and like you know i know we've all
sort of given up on social distancing
people don't really do it anymore but
maybe we should reinstate that but it
shouldn't be
six feet it's like why six maybe 20 feet
so mask mask shield body condom 20 feet
and let's see how this works out for
humans okay let's see if the human
experiment can continue
in the rest of this uh while all of this
lunacy
proliferates throughout society um okay
guys i got a crazy week but there is a
ton going on here
i am leaving for dallas on wednesday and
then we'll be doing live shows live
direct messages
from the blaze studios on thursday and
on friday i'm doing about
20 000 roughly blaze guest appearances
while i'm in town
uh my interview with jason reilly from
the manhattan institute is up by the way
and he has a great documentary
about thomas soule which is out right
now it came out this weekend so you can
find out a little more insider stuff it
was a pleasure to to talk to jason
i'm actually in the documentary as well
but it was a pleasure to talk to jason
about thomas soul who has just
inspired so many people i have no doubt
that he's inspired many of you guys
uh and a lot going on on locals as i
keep telling you so check out
reubenreport.locals.com
have a great day everybody and if
if i don't want to make any promises but
if gavin newsom
within approximately a half hour from
now announces
that california will open including los
angeles and even if the restaurants are
at 25
and outdoors i will send a picture of
three count you know what we're each
getting two chicken sandwiches two
chicken salad you want fries
you want fries fries all right there
will be six
oh wait we should david probably wants
lunch too we will have eight
chicken sandwiches everyone's getting
two things of fries
eight chicken sandwiches eight things of
fries what kind of sauce you want
chick-fil-a sauce what do you want oh
yes there buffalo sauce all right
chick-fil-a sauce buffalo sauce they've
got that polypanisian sauce
they've got the sweet and sour what else
what honey
don't forget the honey mustard maybe a
little ketchup okay we're gonna take a
picture
of chicken outside eating it it's
incredible it's a very exciting time to
be alive
have a great day and gavin newsom i
don't like you
goodbye